SIERRA: Hey Everyone. Usually our show begins by
introducing a topic or a story that you don’t hear
about every day. Well, that’s clearly not the case
when it comes to Putin’s invasion of Ukraine. The
entire world is watching, minute-by-minute. We see
footage of reckless destruction, courageous acts
by Ukrainian citizens and Russian protestors.
We hear the stories of refugees as they flee
Ukrainian cities. SIERRA: We’re all thinking
about it. And judging from the conversations
I’ve been having with family and friends, people
have some basic questions. Like do sanctions work?
Why didn’t we see this coming? And, perhaps
most of all, is this going to turn into a
world war? SIERRA: I had the same questions. So
I went to my boss, CFR President Richard Haass,
and I asked him to join me for a chat in our New
York studio. SIERRA: You may remember Dr. Haass
from previous episodes, including his analysis of
the U.S. withdrawal from Afghanistan. He’s a good
person to talk to at a time like this. He’s served
under four presidents, and has had four decades
of experience with conflict and diplomacy on the
world stage. SIERRA: The conversation you’re about
to hear is largely unedited. We hope it answers
some of your questions and gives you a more solid
foundation for understanding what’s going on.
SIERRA: I’m Gabrielle Sierra and this is Why It
Matters. Today, Ukraine, with Richard Haass.
SIERRA: Okay. Richard Haass, hello.
HAASS:
Good to be back.
SIERRA: Welcome back to Why It
Matters. It feels like I only see you when there's
a crisis. We kinda need to change that up.
HAASS: I do feel like I'm the bad news bear. My
kids for a long time called me daddy downer. But,
to be serious for a second, look, there's a lot
about history, I was just thinking about it,
that's good. Think about our lives, the
average person lives decades longer.
We have the technology, the vaccines they
came out to deal with something like COVID.
Even though we're going to be discussing an attack
on freedom, a lot more people around the world are
living with a degree of democracy and freedom than
in almost any other time of history. We're going
to be talking perhaps about economic sanctions,
but there's more wealth in the world in more
hands than at any time in history. So G*d knows
there's a long list of problems and we're going
to be talking about the biggest immediate one, but
it's not all bad. But there are some things that
are bad or really bad. And there are some things
that will not get better by themselves. There's
nothing about history that leads me to think
that good things are inevitable. Good things
tend to happen when well intentioned people,
who are willing and able to act get together-
SIERRA: Right, it takes work.
HAASS:... and act and push back against those
who are, shall we say, not well intentioned.
SIERRA: Well, so to sort of jump in that way,
a few days ago, I was heading back into the
city with some of my friends, we kind of looked
over and all these buildings in New York
were blue and yellow in support of Ukraine.
And you know it felt very good. It felt
warm. It felt like we were all together
supporting these people who are being bullied,
who are losing their homes, losing their lives.
War is horrible, and what I want to understand
today is why is this conflict different? Why does
this seem more urgent to the world? Because let's
be fair, we also see terrible images from wars
in Yemen and Syria, so what's with this one?
HAASS: Well, as your question suggests, in some
ways it's not so different. This is not the first
time we've seen reckless wanton destruction. It's
not the first time we've seen unwarranted wars,
what I call wars of choice. It's not the first
time we've seen the use of cluster munitions or
other types of bombs that truly constitute war
crimes. Indeed, it's not the first time Russia's
done it recently. It does it regularly in Syria.
So what is different? One, is that it is happening
in Europe. Europe was the venue of so much history
in the 20th century, two World Wars. And then you
had in the aftermath of World War II, the rise of
what we now call the European Union, began through
the European Coal and Steel Community. And there
was a feeling that by having resolved the question
of the French, German, British relationship,
that Europe was going to be safe. And then we had
the Cold War, four decades of U.S. and Soviet led
standoff in Europe, and we got through that and
it remained cold. And it ended peacefully on terms
that were extraordinarily favorable to us. So I
think a lot of people increasingly said, "Okay,
check, we can take Europe off our list." Yes,
we've got to worry about terrorism, 9/11. Yes,
we've got to worry about the Middle East indeed,
a big part of history of the last three decades
has taken place in the greater Middle East,
from Afghanistan, to Iraq, to Syria, to Yemen,
to Libya. But not so much in the terms of conflict
in either Europe. Yes, there was the Balkans and
so forth, but not so much in Europe and obviously
not so much in Asia. Not so much in other parts
of the world. So one, we weren't expecting
it. We thought Europe had reached a different
place in its historical trajectory or arc. And
then secondly, there's something about this,
which is so stark, because Ukraine is a modern
country. I've spent a lot of time there. It's
a modern democracy. And now what's adding to it
is the degree of brutality. There is a starkness
to this. It's not just evil versus good, Russia
versus Ukraine. But there's a medieval quality.
The siege. First, the surrounding of Ukraine with
nearly 200,000 forces. Now the attacks on cities,
on no clear discrimination between military
and civilian targets. This is positively
medieval. Plus one more thing, we're seeing
and reading and hearing about it because
of media and above all social media.
SIERRA: Right. It's all over TikTok.
HAASS: 100%. So one of the things you've learned
over the last few years is that people don't
notice certain awful things in the world if
the cameras can't get in. And there were places
and times in the Middle East or in Africa
where you just didn't have the access. Well
here we've got all the access in the world.
SIERRA: Right there were already influencers,
they're just changing to now covering this war.
HAASS: Exactly. So I think for a lot of people,
this has just broken through, and maybe I've
left out some reasons, but it's broken through
in ways that a lot of foreign
policy and international stuff
just doesn't break through.
SIERRA: Yeah. But why now?
Why is Putin doing this now? Why not
two years ago or two years from now?
HAASS: It's hard to answer with certainty.
Anytime you've got a political system where
decision making is concentrated within one
individual, whether it's North Korea or Russia,
it's pretty hard to assess much less predict.
Indeed, most people didn't predict we would ever
be where we are. So why now? So We're here into
assessments and conjectures. One thing I would
think is in no particular order, opportunity,
he saw the divisions within the United States.
We've had several administrations in a row, three
administrations in a row, Obama, Trump, Biden who
put their priority on things domestic.
SIERRA: Hmm. Interesting.
HAASS: Growing opposition in the United States to
any military engagement. The ignominious departure
from Afghanistan. So part of it is, I think Mr.
Putin got up in the morning and looked at the
United States and saw opportunity.
SIERRA: Was ready.
HAASS: Secondly, he looked at Europe and he saw
the Germans and others, Germans, for example,
canceling nuclear power plants, becoming
incredibly dependent on Russian gas. A new
German government after more than a decade of
Angela Merkel and said, "Ah, a bunch of rookies.
I got a real opportunity in Europe. The French
are worried about elections. The Brits left,
because of Brexit, left Europe. Europe's in
disarray." Another opportunity. Ukraine, well,
Putin has contempt for Ukraine. And this is where
it gets more interesting. It's not just that he
has contempt for Ukraine, but you read his essay
from last summer, he writes about Ukraine in an
almost a mystical way. Talks about fraternalism
and organic relationships between our brotherly
Slavs in Ukraine. So clearly sees this as part
of his legacy. Clearly wants to create a sphere
of influence there. And because he held Ukraine in
contempt or still does, didn't think it would be
that hard to achieve. I think also then there’s
other factors. Yes, he was worried or unhappy
with, to say the least, the enlargement of NATO.
And even though Ukraine was not on the agenda now,
this was still a process that from Mr. Putin's
point of view was awful. He never reconciled
himself to the breakup of the Soviet Union,
which he termed one of the great historical,
you know, awful historical moments, tragedies of
the preceding era. He also, I believe is worried
about the example that Ukraine sets. That even
though Ukraine is an imperfect democracy, it's a
vibrant democracy. And if you remember in 2014,
Mr. Putin intervened, why? Because the people
came into the streets of Ukraine in a so-called
colored revolution and chased the autocrat out
of the palace, in downtown, what we then called
Kyiv and now we call Kiev. If you're a tyrant
like Mr. Putin, there's probably nothing worse
than the precedent of a country that's willing
to challenge authority. So for all these reasons
and more, and I've even at the risk of really
getting into speculation, Gabby, and there's a lot
of speculation out there that Putin's not well and
feels to some extent the pressure of time, it
could be any of these things. It could be all
of these things. It could be things I haven't
mentioned. My own sense is though he clearly
saw a sense of opportunity. And to me, the most
interesting thing about his assessment as best we
can discern it, is how much he underestimated the
challenge. I actually think Vladimir Putin thought
this would be, to use a phrase that was used in
another war, one undertaken by the United States,
a cakewalk. He looked at Ukraine and said, "Ah,
they'll never put up any serious resistance.
United States, they don't have the backbone to
stand up to us. Europeans, ah, we've got them
literally over a barrel of oil." I think Putin
got up and said, "My own military, look how well
we've done in Georgia, Chechnya, Syria, how we did
in Crimea in 2014." I think Putin looked at this
and said, "This is going to be easy. This is fruit
for the taking." And he decided to go for it.
SIERRA: It does sound like it should have
been on our radar a little bit then if all
of this was sort of you know in the works in his
brain, or you just think that like it was just
too far fetched for us to imagine it?
HAASS: It's a really good question. When
you think about intelligence, the business of
intelligence, I don't mean human intelligence,
but intelligence in governments, so much of it is
influenced by mindset and by assumptions. I mean,
one of the more infamous moments is obviously
the weapons of mass destruction fiasco,
when they run up to the Iraq War. I always get a
lot of controversy whenever I talk about it, but I
was in the government then and people legitimately
thought that Saddam Hussein had weapons of mass
destruction. I thought that even though I was
still opposed to the war, but I thought that. But
if you think something, it's the old expression,
if you got a hammer, everything looks like a nail.
Or if you're a doctor and you're looking for this
disease, shockingly enough, you tend to highlight
and emphasize those symptoms that correspond to
the disease and you often tend to dismiss or give
less weight to symptoms that are not consistent
with a certain diagnosis. So I think a lot of
us just weren't thinking that Putin would ever
do anything so blatant or brazen. In that sense,
it's very much like Saddam in the summer of 1990.
I remember then every Arab government saying,
"Oh, don't overreact you Americans. This is just
theater. This is just diplomacy. He's bluffing,
he's pressuring Kuwait. He's never going to
invade." He invaded. And I think right now,
a lot of people just thought that Putin was doing
kind of a modern version of gunboat diplomacy,
was trying to intimidate, was trying to muscle.
Maybe he would do a little bit in the east,
but almost all the experts dismissed or at least
discounted what has now become reality. Again,
assumptions are powerful things. When the
Bush administration in 2003, went into Iraq,
the whole idea that they were going to be met
with children throwing candy instead they were
met with children throwing Molotov cocktails.
I think Mr. Putin had a little bit of that now.
There was a sense that our fraternal brothers
in Ukraine were going to welcome us. Well, guess
what? They're trying to kill Russian soldiers. So
assumptions are powerful and often distorting or
dangerous things. And one of the best things I
actually think, whether governments need to do,
and governments do it by what's called red
teaming, they literally have people who look
at a problem and tackle every assumption. It's
a good thing though, for people to do in your
own life when you think about a situation to
say, "Well, what if this were wrong? What if
this really important assumption turned out to
be wrong? How would that affect everything that
flows from it?" How might I need to change what
I am prepared to do and so forth. And that's the
lesson I take from this, is that mindset and
assumptions can really be dangerous because
they can bias you or worse yet, blind you.
SIERRA: I've heard some bad things about assuming,
so that kind of keeps in the same vein.
HAASS: We're not going to go there.
SIERRA: So, this is Russia after all and sort
of going back to questions that I think a lot
of people are throwing out there. Is
this the beginning of World War III?
HAASS: Well, the Biden administration doesn't
want it to be. I mean, nobody wants it to be,
let me put it that way. Because we avoided a world
war during the cold war and certain rules were,
or unwritten rules were understood
about avoiding direct conflict,
that we could back proxies and allies, but not
come into direct conflict and nuclear weapons
were there above providing a kind of blanket
over the whole thing. And when Khrushchev,
Nikita Khrushchev the Soviet leader backed down in
1962, at the time of the Cuban Missile Crisis, in
some ways that really reinforced that bias against
the use of nuclear weapons, because any victory
would be pyrrhic. Somebody once said the living
would envy the dead. But there were unwritten
rules about avoiding conflict directly, because
that could always escalate. Things could get out
of hand. And the Biden administration essentially
took that possibility off the table by saying, "We
are not going to directly intervene in Ukraine."
And instead, basically developed what you might
call an indirect strategy that they would arm
Ukraine in many ways, they would introduce
economic sanctions against Russia and then take
other steps, reinforce NATO, send extra troops to
NATO, send oil and gas to Europe so it'd be less
dependent upon Russia. But the whole idea was to,
and this early on was to increase the deterrence,
to basically shape Mr. Putin's calculations. So
Mr. Putin would see all these steps or see all
these potential steps like sanctions and say,
"Okay, we're not going to go into Ukraine because
we don't want to trigger all these consequences
for ourselves." So that was the Biden approach.
But again, the reason to take U.S. forces off the
table directly in Ukraine, Ukraine is not a NATO
member. United States does not have that kind of
a commitment to Ukraine. And the concern was
that if we were to do it, it could lead as you
put it to World War III. And also the European
countries were not supportive of it. They too,
as NATO countries did not want things to go
down that path. So what flowed from it was
what you might call an indirect strategy, which
was among other things the most important element
of which is to bolster the ability of Ukraine to
resist Russian invasion. And if Russian invasion,
as it now has, has happened all the same, and
even if Russian invasion succeeds, and Russia
takes quote unquote control of the country and
occupies it, that Ukraine then has the ability
to mount an extremely expensive resistance. And
that's sometimes called the porcupine option or
the Afghan option, which is what among others, the
Soviets experienced in Afghanistan and indeed led
or helped lead to the end of the Soviet Union.
SIERRA: So, I mean, you mentioned, you know nukes,
and I think that's another question
sort of floating out there,
is that something we should be worried
about? Is there a chance we can, if
this escalates that we could get nuked?
HAASS: We didn't think so. And then several days
ago, Vladimir Putin put his nuclear weapons on a
higher state of alert. Now again, why he did that,
we don't know. It might have simply been a
way of intimidating. It might have been his
way of saying don't you cross certain lines,
about helping Ukraine. That there's nothing
I wouldn't do. What I found frightening about it
and worrisome about it is not that he's going to
use nuclear weapons. I don't think he will, but
he could. What Mr. Putin has done over the last
two decades is systematically remove the checks
and balances within the Russian government. The
word I tend to use is deinstitutionalize. And
what he has done is so weakened the bureaucracy,
so weakened any sense of collective leadership
that he's put into his own hands, enormous
power. This was his war. This was not Russia's
war. This was Putin's war of choice. He didn't
have to go in. He certainly didn't have to go
in when he did. He certainly doesn't have to
be following up the way he is. But he enjoys a
degree of discretion that is truly frightening,
because has one of the world's, in many ways the
world's biggest nuclear arsenal. So when he played
that card or waved that card, didn't play that
card, but waved it, I found it alarming. Again,
not that I think he's going to use it, but it was
a real signal of how free he is if not to do that,
to for example, pursue a scorched earth policy in
Ukraine with all sorts of conventional weapons of
mass destruction. To attack much of the world
using cyber. To maybe widen the war against
NATO. To use chemical munitions. That it's not
clear to me who or what inside Russia says,
"Vladimir, you can't do that. That's a step too
far." And that's at the moment, I don't see that
institution or set of individuals there. I hope
that it merges. And indeed that might be-
SIERRA: Me too. That sounds real scary.
HAASS: ... Well, it should. And again,
if you ask me, are nuclear weapons likely to be
used? No. I think the odds are extraordinarily
small. I can't dismiss them.
SIERRA: Right. And there's one
person making that decision.
HAASS: ... That's what worries me
is the concentration of authority in one set
of hands. And it suggests to me that even if
he doesn't go there, he could go to a lot of
other horrible places and dangerous places
and destructive places. And by the way, guess
what? He's already doing that. He's doing it
with this siege of Ukraine cities, and he's
doing it with increasingly indiscriminate
use of extraordinarily violent munitions
against civilian targets. These are terror
weapons. It's one thing to use precision
guided weapons against a military target.
That's what modern war allows you to do. It's
not pretty, but it's what modern war... What
Vladimir Putin is doing is purposely trying to
terrorize a civilian population to essentially
psychologically defeat it. He's having trouble
defeating it militarily. What he wants to do is
defeat it psychological and politically.
SIERRA: So it sounds like one guy decided
to go to war and one guy now has
control over all of the next steps,
and no one to stop him, within Russia.
HAASS: Well, so the question is how could this end
in a way, other than the way we don't want it to
end. We don't want Mr. Putin to succeed. We don't
want him to crush this democracy, this sovereign
country called Ukraine. We don't want to see tens
or hundreds of thousands of Ukrainians die. How
else could it end? So two optimistic scenarios.
One would be that Mr. Putin, for whatever reason,
decides that the costs outweigh the benefits. The
risks are too great. And he decides to pursue a
diplomatic option. Talks started the other day,
made no progress, but that's a possibility. I
think it's at the moment, the longest of long
shots. Negotiations only succeed when the
protagonists are willing and able to make
peace. Mr. Putin is able, I see zero will.
Now, that would have to change. How could it
change? Increasing costs on the battlefield,
or and that gets me to the other approach,
something happens back home, that this combination
of sanctions, maybe the fear of war crimes,
some of the people around him, a really restive
population that can't afford to buy anything
because the ruble is so weak and they have to
import a lot of their goods. ATMs run out of
money. They look at their future and go, "Oh my
God, we're going to be pariahs for the rest of my
life. And I'm only 20 years old. I don't want this
to be my life." That suddenly there is an enormous
amount of popular frustration. And at some point,
whether it gets to the point where the police lose
control, either because the numbers get so great,
or the police lose the will to mow people down.
The other historical analogy that comes to me here
is 78, 79, in Iran. Revolutions against systems,
against powerful for leaders work when there's
massive public push and the security forces,
essentially, aren't prepared any longer to kill
their own people in order to defend this regime.
That's why the Shah became history and was
overthrown just over 40 years ago. We're not
at that point. Could we get to that point? Yes.
The other thing I guess we could get is where
part of this inner circle around Putin, people
sitting at the end of that 40 foot table-
SIERRA: That large table.
HAASS: ... some of them may
decide he's out of control. And that he might
actually use nuclear weapons and the United
States or someone else might do things against
Russia that will set this country back decades.
That what Putin's going to do will so discredit
all of us, the system will come down. And one
has to hope. One has to hope the people with a
degree of proximity and access to Vladimir Putin
are beginning to think this way. One has to hope
they're beginning to talk amongst themselves. It's
risky. Always risky. You're going to be found
out. But one hopes in this combination, again,
of Ukrainian resistance, our ability to retaliate
against certain types of Russian escalation,
even if we're not going to join the battle in
Ukraine, the economic sanctions, the threat of
war crimes, popular dissatisfaction. One has to
hope that this builds some real pressure on the
home front that either Mr. Putin reconsiders or
people essentially move against Putin. And we're
not there yet, but I'm hoping we get there.
SIERRA: I have two questions from that. So one
is where do the people stand at this point? Is
there a lot of opposition to what's going on-
HAASS: In Russia?
SIERRA: ... In Russia? And two is,
tell me more about sanctions, because I think
a lot of people are talking about them and we
kind of don't know, you know, do they work?
HAASS: Right. It's hard to get really detailed
data in the midst of a war, but yes, there's
clearly protests within Russia. Social media
has not been totally shut down, as say it, often
is in China. I can't go sit here and tell you with
confidence that it represents this percent of the
Russian people. I don't think Mr. Putin's done a
terribly effective job of selling the necessity
of this war. I don't know how people will react
to images of Russian soldiers coming back as
casualties or dead. What we're already, actually
beginning to note, Russians are clearly unhappy
with the economic consequences. Thousands, I
believe have been arrested. Stunningly courageous,
by the way, for these people to stand up. There
really is civil society in Russia, which is really
admirable. But whether it will ever get to the
point of being a critical mass, I don't know. But
that's still early days. But that's where we are
in Russia. Indeed, it's hard not to be struck
by the courage and bravery, both of the society
in Ukraine and elements of the society in Russia.
Really, really impressive. And then you asked me
another question. Oh, sanctions.
SIERRA: Sanctions.
HAASS: It's always hard to answer the question, do
sanctions work? So much depends upon how ambitious
you define the word work. If you're asking me,
is there a lot about the history of sanctions?
And by the way, there's a lot of history of
sanctions, because they're used almost all the
time. They tend to be the popular tool between
doing nothing and doing everything. So people
like it. It's option three. It's what's behind
curtain three. Very rarely do sanctions accomplish
big things. Certainly not in a limited amount
of time. The most successful case of sanctions
ever is South Africa. Took a long time and then it
only worked because you had large constituencies
within South Africa, particularly the business
community and a majority of the population that
wanted them to work. I'm not sure any of that
applies here. Sanctions, what they can do is
be extraordinarily punitive. They can exact a
toll. And that's what we're seeing in Russia.
These sanctions are unprecedented. The degree of
a multilateral buy-in we've gotten from Europe,
from the European Union, from governments
that historically have been reluctant, the
Swiss government, German government, and others.
It's quite remarkable this degree of solidarity.
And again, Putin underestimated the breadth and
depth of the sanctions that were going to hit
them. These sanctions against the central bank,
against the oligarchs. Now again, it's not going
to be enough though, I believe directly. It
won't be enough directly to get Putin to stop.
The more interesting question of sanctions
is whether they create fissures or pressures
within Russian society. Putin's probably the
richest man in the world. He's insulated from
sanctions. The question is whether he is
insulated sufficiently from the results of
sanctions on other people and their discontent as
a result. And that's where time becomes a factor.
How quickly do sanctions kick in? Not as
quickly in some cases as one would want.
SIERRA: But it sounds like
it's pretty immediate.
HAASS: Well, some things are. Stock exchange gets
closed regularly now. The Ruble has had dramatic
fall. There'll be shortage of commodities and so
forth. Now we haven't extended sanctions to the
energy sector in Russia, because we're worried
about the fallout there. To me though, the
shorter timeline is what happens on the ground in
Ukraine. To me, the greater need is for more arms,
particularly relevant arms; anti-tank weapons,
anti-aircraft systems to get into Ukraine's
hands quickly. We're talking hours and days. We're
not talking about hours and days with sanctions.
Sanctions tend to play out over a longer time or
horizon. What's critical is what happens literally
in the next week, on the ground in Ukraine.
SIERRA: Right, okay. Interesting. I feel like
I've got my head around sanctions now, which
is probably a good thing to do. I think also
something that people are talking about and you
know sanctions are part of that conversation,
is what about troops? I know you mentioned
there's a pretty specific reason why we're
not sending in troops, but is that
on the table at all? Will it be?
HAASS: President Biden took it off the table
very early on. I can't tell you why. My own
sense of it, my own reading of it is that
he didn't think the American people would
be behind it. What you're seeing is a real
allergy to foreign military interventions
in this country. And also there wasn't European
support for it, to turning it into a NATO war.
And also because out of concern that it would very
quickly potentially become an east-west, or what
used to call an east-west conflict, U.S.-Russian
conflict. And it would've gone against the
behavior during the Cold War that kept the cold
war cold. We avoided direct confrontations.
So he opted for what I would call an indirect
strategy. The principal military element, was to
provide arms and some intelligence to Ukraine and
thought that could sufficiently raise the cost of
either invasion or more likely an occupation, was
hoping that would deter Russia. Clearly it didn't
work. Now he's on plan B, which is to provide
enough arms to raise the costs of the invasion and
occupation to a level that the Russians don't want
to pay, in lives. It's clearly slowing them down.
The first couple of days of the war did not go
well for Mr. Putin. And the fact that the Russians
are escalating with these terrible conventional
mass casualty munitions and by introducing far
more troops tells you that, that essentially
what Mr Putin is doing is doubling down. And
what we need to do, I would argue, is double
down in response and get as many of the relevant
weapons as quickly as we can into Ukraine's
hands. You see these massive convos forming,
and yes, you can shoot some of them with anti-tank
weapons. There's things you can use, artillery or
what have you against trucks. It would be good if
you had some aircraft that could fly to take out
some of these convoys. But that's where we are.
SIERRA: So shifting a little to look domestically,
we do see some Americans and
even some American politicians
supporting Putin. So do you think that
our political polarization sort of hurts
our ability to act in situations like these?
HAASS: Again, we're into the land of assessment
here. My own sense is it contributed to Mr.
Putin's confidence. That the United States
would be too divided to mount a-
SIERRA: All that disarray.
HAASS: ... an effective response. And he had
gotten used to, in particular, working with
president Trump and people around him who had
a, let's just call it what it is, a pro-Russian
view of the world. Some of these people said the
real enemy isn't Russia, the real enemy is China.
So my own sense is he thought we would be too
divided to mount an effective political response,
which is a prerequisite for the rest of our
response, from military, from sending arms,
to sanctions, what have you, and he was wrong.
That what we see is most Americans are rallying
around this president, who by the way is not a
popular president. The most recent polls still
show Mr. Biden, what, south of 40%?
SIERRA: Yeah. Yeah.
HAASS: In favorable ratings, going into the
state of the union. But most people seem
supportive. This is pretty black or white. This is
pretty democracy versus evil. So much of life is
the fifth 51/49 kind of decision. This is not at
the 51/49 yard lines. This is, we got end zones.
This is pretty clear cut. What you're seeing is
a good number of Republicans coming around to
supporting the administration. They're not taking
the political step of criticizing Donald Trump.
For a lot of them that would be a bridge too far.
But they're clearly distancing themselves from a
Trump-like policy, which has been an enabling of
Russia and sympathetic to Russia for the past,
what, five years. So some Republicans can't bring
themselves to support a democratic president even
when he is right. And I'll be honest, I've worked
for three Republican presidents, one democratic
president. I think the Biden administration has
handled this well for the most part. I think
they do deserve support, do deserve praise.
For some Republicans that's a bridge too far,
but some Republicans are. I think actually are
supporting them. I actually think there is a
degree of bipartisanship that has-
SIERRA: Come around.
HAASS: ... come around here. So there's still a
recognizable Republican party somewhere there.
A bit in camouflage, a bit buried. But it may be
down, but it's not out. And you listen to somebody
like Mitt Romney and it's there in full force
and Mitt Romney's the guy who years ago said,
"Russia is the biggest threat." And looks rather,
shall we say vindicated? On the democratic side,
there's a lot more support, not complete,
but the bulk of the democratic party in a
surprising amount of the, particularly the
Washington or institutional Republican party
on this issue seems to be supporting our policy
if not supporting President Biden per se. If not
opposing former President Trump, per se.
SIERRA: You know you mentioned a couple of
times people coming together, do you think
that this war could change anything about how
the world works? Or do you think we're just
going to go back to business as usual?
HAASS: I think there's a couple of silver linings
already. One is the reemergence of Europe. Both
the European Union, as well as the transatlantic
relationship in NATO, plus this new German
government. What's happened in recent days and
weeks, if we'd had this conversation a month ago,
I would've said, "That'd be great, but ain't
going to happen." So remarkable turnaround,
in a stunningly small amount of time. Europe has
really stepped up. The fact that this new German
government is talking about spending 2% or more
of its GDP on defense, we couldn't get them to
do that for decades. There's a real recognition
I think that Mr. Putin represents something very
different and very dangerous. And that this
Putin is perhaps different than the Putin we
thought we knew. I think economic sanctions have
been shown to be more potentially effective than
people thought. And I'm hoping that influences
Chinese behavior on something like Taiwan.
That the Chinese will say to themselves, "Wow.
Look at the price that the Russians have to pay.
Look how difficult it is for them." By the way,
the Americans aren't intervening in Ukraine. Well,
the Americans may well, I believe, would intervene
in a Taiwan contingency. So I think for China,
this has to get them to think more than
twice about any dreams they may have had
of invading Taiwan.
SIERRA: Interesting.
HAASS: I don't know, in our country. I'm
hopeful that this will do something to revive
both bipartisanship a bit, but also a sense
of the importance of democracy and freedom
and values. That what we are seeing is
there's still evil in the world. And
that countries that believe in democracy and
freedom have to stand up and work together.
And what I'm also hoping is it discredits people
in this country who have cozied up to Russia,
as well as in places like Europe who have cozied
up to Russia, the far right in France. That it
discredits them. And I'm hoping that one of the
unanticipated positive consequences of Mr. Putin,
this is a great irony here, here's this guy who
did all this to, in social media and elsewhere,
to undermine American democracy. He may have
actually revived it a little bit. He may have
actually reminded us about why democracy
matters and why we need to work together
sometimes. And that would be the-
SIERRA: And that it's not assumed.
HAASS: Don't assume anything. That is the lesson
of the last few years, whether you're talking
about foreign policy or domestic policy
or American democracy or anything else.
Don't assume anything.
SIERRA: Anything. Well then
with all of this, why does this matter?
HAASS: I think it's the most important
question. That we have to see the
connections between what is going on here.
And this is to me, the basic lesson of history.
Everything we do as a society, as an economy, as
individuals, depends upon there being order in the
world. Think about how our lives were disrupted by
a virus. Think about how our lives were disrupted
by a handful of terrorists on 9/11. Obviously, for
our parents or grandparents generations about how
our lives were disrupted by World War II. Order
out there is something that we take for granted at
our peril, because everything we are as a society,
as families, as businesses, as economies,
depends on our ability to go to work safely,
go to school safely and so forth. And the
most basic feature of that order in the
world is the idea that countries, governments,
which have the most capability in their hands,
don't invade other countries. That they respect
borders. And the last time this was ignored
wholesale was World War II. It gets ignored every
now and then since then, but never wholesale.
This is the most basic tenant, principle, norm,
this thread of the fabric, of order in the world.
And if Mr. Putin is allowed to get away with
what he's doing, why does anyone think, one,
that he will stop there? In my experience, people
on a roll rarely stop. It's kind of Newton's Law,
objects in motion remain in motion. And then
secondly, why do we think others wouldn't follow
suit? Why do we think others wouldn't take notes?
Interestingly enough, when we in 1990, stood up
to Saddam Hussein in Operation Desert Storm,
that was the logic. What was different then,
it was at the dawn of the post Cold War era.
The wall had just come down a year before,
the Berlin wall. And President Bush, the father
essentially said, How we react to this, what we
do and don't do will, will shape the character of
the next era of history." And we thought that if
Saddam got away with it, not only would Saddam
come to dominate the Middle East and its energy
and all that, but we said others would take notes
and there would be other Saddams out there. They
would calculate they could get away with it in
every part of the world. That's where we are now.
It's not just what Vladimir Putin would do if he
gets on a roll, what he might do about NATO and
other countries in Europe. But second of all, if
we did nothing, what might China then do about a
Taiwan. Or what an Iran might do or North Korea.
And countries that have been dependent on us,
who look to us for help would say, "Wow, we
can't depend on these guys. They did nothing.
So either we're going to have to sell out, defer
to our powerful neighbor and kind of let them
run our lives, which is what Russia wanted
with Ukraine. Or we're going to have to say,
get nuclear weapons of our own." Think about
that, if suddenly we have a world where everybody
decides they need to scramble to get their own
nuclear weapons and what happens the first time
there's a crisis. So that more than anything
else is why this matters. I know words like
world order sound terribly wonky-
SIERRA: Yeah. And I was going to
say also a little abstract to give to
just someone when they're like, "Well,
why does this hit me at home?" Like you mentioned
9/11 and COVID, those things directly affected
people right here. Whereas you're saying,
"Oh, people will take notes, the world order,
there's all this." I think that's a little
more... It's just not as direct for people.
HAASS: When I say take notes, take notes is not
all they're going to do. They're then going to
take those notes and they're going to invade
neighbors. They're going to develop nuclear
weapons. They're going to stamp out democracy and
freedom. And why do we think we would be immune
potentially from the consequences of their actions
or aggression? One of the lessons in this world,
this show is about, why does it matter, well, the
basic lesson of living in an interconnected world
is that almost everything matters. There ain't
no there versus here. They are interwoven. And
we're naive if we think that awful stuff can
happen and then it gets compartmentalized.
SIERRA: Sure.
HAASS: It'll spread. So there's that. We also care
about things like freedom and human life.
SIERRA: Of course.
HAASS: Foreign policy isn't just cold blooded,
realpolitik. It isn't just about quote unquote
“order.” It's also about human lives. It's
about freedom, and it's about democracy and
values. And we don't want to see good people
left in the lurch. One way or another we have
to help them. In this case indirectly, by giving
them economic and military help and diplomatic
help and everything else. In some cases we might
want to help them directly. And that's a tactical
decision we have to make. But we believe in
things that are bigger than ourselves. This
was a country founded on an idea. That's the
whole concept that's at the core of American
nationhood. We believe in ideas. We believe
in values. And so I believe American foreign
policy has to worry about things like order
because that will affect us. That's real stuff.
That will affect our interests, our security, our
prosperity, all that matters. That's real stuff.
But also foreign policy should be about it more
than that. We are against genocides, even if we're
not dying in the genocide. Why? Because we believe
genocide is wrong. We believe in human rights,
even if it's not Americans whose human rights will
be affected for the better, because we believe in
those things. So foreign policy's always got
to be a matter of interest, but also values.
And I would argue it gets in trouble when it's
one or the other. It can't just be a crusade
on behalf of values, but it just can't be cold
blooded, narrow interest. It's got to have a
balance of the two. So that's why this matters.
SIERRA: Well, I think this was extremely helpful
for me and I'm sure it will be for a lot of
other people. So thank you for joining us.
Hopefully next time maybe we could talk about
something really happy, versus always seeing
you under these circumstances.
HAASS: I hope it's about golf.
SIERRA: One can dream. Hope.
HAASS: ... One can dream.
SIERRA: Thank you.
SIERRA:
For resources used in this episode and more
information, visit CFR.org/whyitmatters and take
a look at the show notes. SIERRA: Have a question
or some feedback? Just feel like saying hi? Send
us an email at whyitmatters@cfr.org. Subscribe
to the show on Apple Podcasts, Spotify, Stitcher,
or wherever you get your audio. And if you are a
fan, we’d love it if you could leave us a review.
Ideally a good one, the more stars the better. It
really does help us get noticed. Why It Matters is
a production of the Council on Foreign Relations.
The show is created and produced by Asher Ross,
Jeremy Sherlick, and me, Gabrielle Sierra. Our
sound designer is Markus Zakaria. Rafaela Siewert
is our associate podcast producer. Our intern is
Roshni Rangwani. Robert McMahon is our Managing
Editor, and Doug Halsey is our Chief Digital
Officer. Extra help for this episode was provided
by Kali Robinson. Original music is composed by
Ceiri Torjussen. Special thanks go to Richard
Haass and Jeff Reinke. For Why It Matters, this
is Gabrielle Sierra signing off. See you soon!